there's been a ton of hype for Apple's
M3 MacBook Air coming later this year
but unfortunately we've been seeing some
rumors claiming that it's actually
getting delayed until
2024. so even though I really hope this
isn't true I want to keep you guys
informed on all the leaks so in this
video I'm gonna give you five reasons
why this delay could make sense as well
as my own personal prediction on when
it'll be launched so let's get into the
first reason which is the leaker Tech
Reeve on Twitter just over a week ago
Tech Reef claimed that the M3 powered
Max were delayed until 2024 which was a
huge surprise to me until I found out
why but the crazy thing is that it
matches new updated info from a very
reliable leaker Ming shaquo which he
posted on Twitter mentioning that the
15-inch MacBook Air would get the M2
Chip and that the M3 chip would only
enter mass production in the second half
of 2023 slightly ahead of M3 Pro and M3
Max mass production now that detail is
very important because I Apple's chips
usually start mass production a while
before the launch of the actual product
getting that chip for example tsmc
started three nanometer chip production
at the end of December which is almost
certainly Apple's a17 bionic chip for
the iPhone 15 Pro but that's only coming
in September so that's nine months ahead
of schedule and then in 2021 the M1 Pro
and Max chips which everyone mistakenly
thought would be called the M2 entered
mass production in April but it wasn't
until six months later that the chips
actually launched in October with the
redesigned MacBook Pros so if makes you
quote is right and the M3 chip starts
mass production in the second half of
this year which begins in July six
months later at a minimum would be
January of next year if the M3 sticks to
the same timeline as before so if the M3
somehow does get launched this fall it
would be on an extremely tight schedule
with limited chips apply and that's
exactly what reason number two is
limited supply of tsmc's three nanometer
chips which is actually the main reason
for all of the M3 MacBook Air hype since
it should be insanely efficient and fast
by my personal estimations based on
leaked a17 bionic benchmark scores that
were sheared by Tech Reeve but it was
actually a huge leak from weibo's user
937840 who also said that the
progression of the M3 would be after the
a17 backing up with quo said but then on
March 20th Tech Reef came back and said
that tsmc is surprisingly struggling
with three nanometer chips leading to
lower goals for the a17 specifically
saying that both the yield and
performance of three nanometer are below
their target which means that we might
not see benchmark scores as high as the
a17 leak as well as my own M3
estimations he then revealed his
reasoning which was that apparently
tsmc's three nanometer chip yield was
less than 50 percent which is terrible
and then over a month later on April
25th we got reports from other sources
that tsmc is in fact struggling to make
enough three nanometer chips for Apple's
a17 and M3 chips now having
approximately 55 yield which is still
bad and then three days later Tech Reef
told us how he knew tsmc was struggling
and it was the fact that N3 should have
started production in the spring if it
had proceeded on a normal road map or
timeline but according to minshe quo
it's only happening in the second half
of this year so because of that he
revealed that the M3 has been delayed
until next year and even the a17 will
face similar yield issues not in the
form of a delay but instead having
reduced performance to compensate for
the lower yields so basically the main
idea is that 55 yields on M3 chip isn't
enough for both the M3 and a17 leading
to the delay of M3 Max to 2024 which
Tech Reef confirmed again on May 2nd now
getting into reason number three there's
a rumor going around that Apple has a
huge stockpile of M2 chips laying around
that they're struggling to sell off and
there's actually really good evidence
for this the rumor comes from Hachi tech
on Twitter who basically said that Apple
has a severe oversupply of M2 chips even
suggesting that the 24 inch iMac is
about to be garbage because originally
it was supposed to get the M3 chip but
now they're gonna give it the M2 just to
sell more M2 chips the reason for that
is of course because they need to find
ways to sell more M2 chips and
apparently that's another reason why
Apple has decided to give the 15-inch
MacBook Air the M2 which is expected
next month and this has already been
confirmed by many sources including
minchikuo and Mark German in Tech
even said that the Apple TV gaming
console is coming soon potentially also
with an M2 Chip he essentially said that
the M2 Max sales numbers are so bad that
he wouldn't be surprised if Apple gave
every iPad an M2 Chip just to sell off
more of them need proof that idea is
true well Apple reportedly stopped
production of their new M2 Chip in
January and February because their M2
Max just weren't selling well enough and
that's something that hasn't happened
before for a six month old new chip and
then when they eventually resume
production it was only at 50 percent of
the rate of previous years this proves
that Apple's M2 chips were not getting
sold fast enough and they likely have a
huge stockpile of them that they don't
want to make even bigger especially with
the M3 chip already on its way so
basically a big reason to delay the M3
until 2024 is to give the M2 chips time
to sell off and that leads us into
reason number four the rest of the
industry is delaying and canceling three
nanometer chip products especially Intel
who recently canceled even more of
tsmc's three nanometer projects so the
idea here is that Apple can essentially
stretch out their M2 line especially
since the competition still hasn't even
caught up to the M2 even though it was a
stop Gap release so instead of rushing
to launch M3 products so quickly they
could release more M2 Chip products that
are still going to sell very well anyway
and then when the M3 comes out everyone
who bought M1 or M2 Chip Max will feel
like they're missing out because of the
huge performance and efficiency gains
and they'll be even more likely to
upgrade sooner even if they wait until
the M4 which will also be on three
nanometer and because of that we're
likely getting the M2 15-inch MacBook
Air and we could even end up with more a
crappy M2 Chip updates later this year
which will end up being press releases
instead of being revealed at events
including probably an M2 iPad air update
later this fall and now finally for
reason number five we have macro
economic factors or essentially the
looming recession the big idea here is
that the M3 chip is gonna be a huge deal
since it'll be using the industry's
first three nanometer chips from tsmc
with huge improvements I'm personally
predicting the M3 MacBook Air to have
the best battery life in any Macbook so
if Apple has such a great product coming
why risk releasing it during a recession
where people simply aren't buying Max
anyway that could even be why Apple
recently delayed plans for their 27 inch
display with mini LED and promotion
technology as well as maybe even
delaying the overdue Mac Pro people
aren't really buying Max right now and
we know that for sure because Max sales
have dropped 40 percent year over year
even worse than all the other PC Brands
likely because Mac products are the most
expensive on top of that many companies
are cutting their budgets including
everything from products to advertising
which is why we're seeing so many
layoffs as well as business closures
like news media companies just look at
Google who is cutting costs by buying
less staplers tape and of course giving
their employees cheap Chromebooks by
default instead of other nice laptops
like MacBooks and I'm sure other
companies are doing the same thing to
save money on top of that Apple's main
iPhone Manufacturing Company Foxconn
just announced a 56 drop in profits
compared to last year so in this
environment companies are doing
everything they can to save money
because people simply aren't spending
money like they used to so in the case
of the M3 MacBook Air why release it
when we're in the middle of a recession
when they can just keep giving us simple
M2 Chip swapped Max until the economy
starts recovering again hopefully early
next year being great timing for the M3
MacBook Air and now let me finish off
with my personal prediction I think that
even though all of these reasons since I
believe Apple will still release the M3
MacBook Air in the fall simply because
it matches up to their 1.5 year update
cycle and even if the supply of three
nanometer chips is low I believe they
could reveal the M3 Max in November but
with limited Supply so it could sell out
very quickly until chip Supply improves
later in December or January so there
you guys go those were my thoughts
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign